[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists get the tick-tock
machine ready danny unknown
did we buy one of those
[Music]
i think it's just his iphone oh okay
ryan people
frequently visit places like the
container store
to purchase clutter coffins
to hide their hordes but the best way to
organize your stuff isn't to store it in
a basement mausoleum the best way to
organize
is to get rid
of the excess stuff today on the public
podcast we're going to discuss america's
obsession
with storing useless stuff
then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast ryan and i are going to
record an episode about the kind of
spring cleaning that works all year long
you can check that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
because advertisements suck
all right y'all our first question today
is from kathy on patreon can we talk
about the rise of the storage business
what a broad question every year rises i
mean
since probably post-industrial age i'm
assuming like that's when it's really
started to
just get worse and worse year over year
it has continued i mean and here's the
weird thing and we're going to go into
some stats here in a moment
this is a uniquely american problem
yeah we have more storage we have more
storage uh facilities like square foot
wise than we do homes correct we have
more storage facilities than the rest of
the world combined
dude you know how many that is it's over
52 000 storage facilities over over
across the country which is more than
six times the number of starbucks that
is um it's crazy
and there are a lot of starbucks in this
country yes
in fact maybe we could turn the
starbucks into storage facilities or
[Laughter]
ryan so uh to answer kathy's question
here by the way kathy thank you for
being a patron yeah you keep the podcast
advertisement free i have 63
self-storage industry statistics and
trends for 2022.
and so i'm not going to read all 63 of
these stats for you here just give us
the the juicy ones the first one here is
the global self-storage market was
valued at 48
billion dollars in 2020. we got in the
wrong business milburn
we're talking people out of their stuff
we should have gotten into the business
of helping people hoard their stuff we
could have done both
get it out of your home and put it into
storage then you'll be happy right it
always cracks me up when i see a lot of
these storage places will
you know like the big storage places
they have social media accounts and
they'll often share our documentaries
from netflix
encouraging people to declutter their
stuff but not to let go of it yeah to
simply pay them money to hold on to it
for them
but of course if you're letting go of it
physically but storing it you're not a
you're not even letting go of it
physically but b it's still weighing on
the back of your mind it's taking up
space yeah and it's also extracting
resources out of your bank account yeah
here's one for you over 88 percent of
renters are between the ages of 21 and
55. oh that was shocking to me that is
shocking i would think it would be more
of a like
50 to 80 like you know because you
that's
near the end of your of your life or
you're you're a lot of the way through
your life i should say yes and you've
collected so many things
but that statistic tells me that at
about 50 people start to realize
why am i holding on to all this stuff or
at around age 55 people saying why am i
paying for all the storage i'll just
hoard this stuff in my house oh yeah
right yeah remember ryan i had a two and
a half car garage
i don't even know what that means what
the hell is a half a car
but what it really means is oh there's
enough space
in here to store all of my junk yeah and
so we're going to talk about why this is
a problem here's one other very unique
stat and this is why i say it's a
uniquely
american problem i didn't mean to say
very unique nothing can be very unique
it's either unique or it isn't unique
but anyway this is a uniquely american
problem because more than 90 of the self
storage industry is in the united states
now quite often clutter
and the inability to let go these aren't
american problems they're worldwide
problems but we have found a new way to
hide our clutter that's why i opened the
show
talking about clutter coffins clutter
coffins yeah i got this idea because i
saw an advertisement i was walking down
the street it was like a little
billboard on a bench
that was advertising coffins
and i saw it was a very cluttered ass oh
i'm spilling coffee on myself it was a
very cluttered ad man only in la why
would you have a billboard or a yeah an
advertisement for coffins yeah right
it's a very strange thing right
in fact i i feel like i would see
something like that in the midwest but
no i saw it here
anyway it was the advertisement for
coffins
and it was a very cluttered ad and i'm
like oh cluttered coffins wait a minute
clutter coffins yeah that's really what
we're doing we go to the container store
or walmart or target we buy these
plastic bins alabama's getting me a
paper towel thank you malaban yes like
especially with the storage units like
it's the um
so the clutter coffins is are the
storage uh uh the storage rubber storage
containers you put underneath your bed
where the actual
uh storage facility is is it called a
mausoleum like what is it called when
you have like the big tomb yes that's a
mausoleum it's a mausoleum yes okay
that's like the yeah it's the mausoleum
of the clutter coffins right we've
turned our homes into mausoleums or our
basements our attics our walk-in closets
our spare bedrooms these are just
mausoleums and we have all these little
individual clutter coffins right and we
treat it as though oh this will solve my
problem my problem is i'm not organized
enough well no i can tell you from
firsthand experience my problem was that
i was too
organized and i wasn't willing to let go
of anything here you go alabama thank
you
yeah it's interesting because
i think storage units they have their
they do have their function they do have
their place like i use as a minimalist
like i had a storage unit for like six
months uh when we moved out to montana
i'm like wait what did i say we'll be
ruined
yeah so when we moved out to montana i
had a storage unit uh because i didn't
think we would be out in montana as long
as we were so i had a bunch of stuff in
my apartment i was like i'm gonna a
washer and dryer and um just some other
things a chair
uh it was the smallest storage unit they
had available put my stuff in there
and turns out we were in montana longer
than six months but that was my
that was my uh limit i was like if we're
out there longer than six months i'm
gonna get rid of that storage unit and
get rid of my stuff so i um yeah we went
back to ohio i had a yard sale actually
it was more like a
um a storage sale i just literally put
an ad in the paper hey here's my storage
unit number come out and buy some stuff
everything must go that's like a setup
yeah i know right yeah i i'm you someone
might get killed in this scenario you'd
be really careful yeah but uh but yeah
it was great when people came i got rid
of all my stuff and then i got rid of
the storage unit so you know in that
situation it was totally useful for me
it served a purpose yes um i know that
when you were kind of in between places
in la you had the um what is it called
the whatever it is the mobile pod i
forget what they call it yeah and so i
didn't i was i was homeless for a short
period of time i was home full as colin
would say
i no i we were moving and i and there
was a there was an overlap between the
two places we were going to be in so it
was a couple weeks where we needed a
place to put our things our couch our
bed yeah etc right until i had the
opportunity to move it into our new
apartment when the current tenants moved
out right yeah and so i think that's a
great point ryan i'm not i don't want to
renounce storage there is certainly a
place for it and the same thing is true
even with these clutter coffins with
storage containers in fact alabama we
could use a few of them so maybe i'm
gonna get alabama to go down and buy
three storage containers okay now sean
you really do have to bleep that out
and here's why like when we go down to
uh we have a closet downstairs and we
call it the annex and it's basically we
keep extra cables and things for the
studio and right now we do it in like uh
these ugly
cardboard boxes
that are just random boxes and is there
a better way to stack and store the
things that we know we use regularly but
don't want cluttering up the space yes
absolutely yes and we could have a few
storage containers for that without it
being a problem because as soon as you
renounce something you're forever
tethered to it amen so i'm not saying
get rid of storage
containers i'm not saying get rid of
storage facilities the problem is when
we rely on these things to hide our
problem when they become part of the
problem
and they masquerade as though they're
the solution well a lot of the times
it's the easy solution what do i do with
all my stuff well just out of sight out
of mind i'll pay for a storage unit put
it all in there it's much more difficult
to actually go through your stuff to to
sell it to figure out what to donate to
figure out what needs what needs to be
recycled um it's yeah it's it's a it's a
quick fix for a lot of reasons i think
right and it just hides the problem it's
punting in a way but you're punting to
yourself and you're still gonna have to
pick this thing back up and it's punting
in the sense that it puts you way way
back from where you want to be right and
so
yes if you want to store your things
temporarily because it makes sense great
wonderful but if there isn't an end date
or if there isn't a plan in place and
i'm just going to hold on to this it's
just a different type of clinging it's
extending
your parameter of clinging i wonder how
many people here
uh listening to this
have a storage
uh unit
with uh you know however filled it is
how much they've spent on that over the
last year two years three years four
years five years
versus how much their stuff is actually
worth
ooh yeah go to the youtube video let us
know how much have you been spending on
storage lockers that you don't access
regularly and when i say regular you're
not going there at least once a month
yeah right and again if you have some
sort of end date i need to store this
stuff for six months it totally makes
sense because
it would make more sense to do that than
to go out and buy all new things and be
incredibly wasteful the problem is the
story that we often tell ourselves is
what oh it'd be wasteful for me to let
go of these things i might need them
someday
and then some day never arrive someday
is not a day of the week it's not a day
of the year it's some hypothetical day
in the future and so we hold on to it
for some day some day doesn't arrive but
i'm holding on to it why just in case go
back and watch our just in case
episode as well we did a whole episode
on just in case items and many of the
items that end up in these storage
facilities are just in case items here's
a few more stats for you ryan this one
was i don't know if it was shocking but
i don't know i didn't really have an
expectation here so approximately 65 of
self storage renters are women but
almost 90
of people moving into the self storage
unit are men
so like it seems that the women are all
and they and this could often be in a
marriage perhaps are the ones who are
renting the space or using the space
but then they're asking their husbands
or brothers or fathers to move the stuff
into the hey can you move my horde for
me and i know because i used to ask ryan
to help me move my horde around this
makes me yeah it makes me think about
your mom's horde yeah when she was
moving down to florida and she had that
storage unit and uh yeah we were helping
the movers with all her stuff yeah that
was
man yeah that was
fun that's the thing it's actually never
fun no whenever you're dealing with all
of these things and this is why ryan did
his packing party
12 years ago
it was 12 years ago that you did this
packing party because you knew we knew
when we came up with this idea
oh
this is the one time you have to
confront all of your things when you
have to move it and so no one ever goes
to their storage locker when they're
moving stuff out and saying i wish i
would have stored more things that i
need to
move
i wish i would have held on to more
useless junk no one ever says i wish i
had more stuff that isn't adding value
to my life no one ever says i need more
non-essential items in my life no one
ever stops and says
please
please give me more junk give me the
capacity to hold more junk in these
clutter coffins in these mausoleums of
stuff
and so
we've got oh actually you know what
podcast john put a link to this article
in the show notes there are 63 different
stats if you want to
read more of them uh gen x is the
generation so that's often we're we're
cuspers but gen x are the is the
generation who's storing the most stuff
right now oh really yes interesting and
also here was one other one here's how
you know well here's why you know there
are so many
storage facilities popping up everywhere
as you said more than six times the
number of starbucks yeah
because their profit margin
is 41
the entire industry so that means some
of them their profit margin is excess of
a hundred percent so
a grocery store that is doing phenomenal
their profit margins single digits um
five six seven eight nine percent
if you're a grocery store is doing
really well maybe you make 10
storage facilities their profit margin
is 41
wow and so they're making a ton of money
renting out all of this space
to you
and in a way they're sort of taking
advantage of
you because
they're taking advantage of your desire
to cling
they're taking advantage of the of what
they know
americans in particular human beings
aren't capable of letting go anymore now
we have been capable for millions of
years and you see it in children they
let go so easily
my daughter's dog died this weekend oh
it was super sad yeah he was um
like 14 years old right so it wasn't
unexpected he's been
going downhill for the last year or so
and um
she was super super sad on sunday and
then on saturday and then on sunday she
went ice skating and i have a picture of
her with the biggest most beautiful look
on her face
and
there was a mourning period there was a
lamenting there she's not a sociopath
she didn't laugh at the dog dying
obvious she was very saddened by it
but she was also able to let it go and i
think if she was three years old she
would have even had an easier time to
let go she's eight now almost nine
and so
we cling
we cling to the way we wish things were
we cling to the past
in fact ryan there's this uh we always
talk about being in the moment or being
present right
that's really just a
boutique way of saying
stop clinging to the past
stop clinging to the outcome of
something that might happen in the
future that's the only way to be in the
moment is to not cling to the past to
not cling to the future because if we're
not doing those things then we are
actually being in the moment
however these clutter coffins these
storage lockers they're just another way
for us to cling to the past the
artifacts of the past the signifiers of
the past or they're a way for us to
cling to our idealized version of the
future if i just have all of the right
things at the right time in the right
sequence and the right house in the
right town
then i'll be complete then i'll be happy
it doesn't work out that way though no
kathy thank you so much for your
question let's move on to our callers
here if you have a question or comment
for our podcast
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
looks like we have a question here from
catherine in ontario canada ever since i
was pregnant with my daughter i've been
trying to minimize the things that i own
at the time i was not only receiving a
lot of things from my daughter but i was
also realizing that someday the things
that i own will go to her
i it has definitely been an ongoing
process however since that time i found
it hard to continue doing something that
i have always found value in
scrapbooking
i now see that scrapbooking will in turn
create books of photos that will someday
be left my daughter to decide what to do
with ever since high school i have loved
scrapbooking i feel like i have always
been very conscious of limiting the
amount of scrapbooking supplies that i
own
i create pages that do not have too many
embellishments
since i am a graphic designer and
photographer
scrapbooking is a relaxing creative
outlet that helps me organize my
thoughts and memories into something
that i get joy out of looking at in the
years to come
for me scrapbooking has meant keeping
memorabilia like cards and ticket subs
from events that i have experienced and
then incorporating them with photos to
create a designed journal of my life
since i have been scrapbooking since
1997 i have 11 12 by 12 books
i haven't been able to continue
scrapbooking since 2017 with this
looming knowledge that in another 20
years there could possibly be 22 books
in total i have also been reading zero
waste home by bia johnson which makes me
feel very aware of the things i throw in
the garbage such as photograph scraps
i wanted your advice since i actually
get a lot of joy out of not only
creating them but looking at them
i know that you have in the past given
advice to display your photos in digital
frames
and carefully selected artwork around
your home however in the situation i
feel like the act of creating something
that is tactile and can be flipped
through later is part of what i enjoy
i've been feeling a little stuck ever
since i stopped scrapbooking and i look
forward to hearing your response
you know catherine uh josh and i what we
try to help people do is set boundaries
up for themselves
and
you know josh and i could sit here and
give you some tips on well you know uh
um
limited to how many books you have
limited to how many pages i mean we
could sit here and suggest some
boundaries but really catherine it's up
to you
to set the boundaries so she stopped
scrapbooking because she wanted to be a
minimalist essentially that's the most
upsetting part of it it really is
because it brought her joy it brought
her
a sense of purpose it was it was an art
really
and yeah for someone to stop their art
because they want to be a minimalist
yeah that is really sad this is the
unfortunate side of legalism or rules
right restrictive rules now sometimes
temporarily setting up some rules will
help you find your boundaries right
your healthy boundaries the boundaries
that help you thrive and be more
creative catherine this is a creative
act what you're doing yeah and if you
had 22 scrapbooks 20 years from now or
whatever it might be
that could be a beautiful thing
you are creating art you're an artist
and the last thing i want to do is tell
you to stop doing it because you read
some zero waste book that discouraged
you from producing any waste whatsoever
this isn't waste yes there are
byproducts of what you're creating you
may not be able to use everything you
create just like i'm a writer right and
so when i write a novel and it's 200 000
words but you publish 60 000 words
there's some waste there and actually
some of it is actual physical paper i
print out things i write longhand
sometimes and so when i write i am
producing a little bit of waste yeah but
if
if it meant hey you have to stop riding
because you can't produce any waste
whatsoever and are there ways to dispel
display these things digitally yes but
if it's not giving you that same fuel
that same aliveness
that that feeling of being who you are
so catherine i want to communicate
something important to you here
i know you're worried about okay years
from now
i might have to pass these on to my
daughter
and
she may not get value from these that
might be true but you are not creating
these for your daughter if you were
simply and solely creating these for
your daughter i would say oh pause
does she want these
but this is for you now if your daughter
ends up getting value from them a year
from now
a decade from now two decades from now
wonderful that is a bonus but you're
doing this to create art right now and i
applaud you for that yeah and it's not
that you need my permission or ryan's
permission to keep doing this but it
would be really really unfortunate
to stop producing the art that makes you
feel
alive let's talk about the zero waste
thing for a second
i i
first off i admire anyone who is trying
to live a zero waste lifestyle i admire
someone who is environmentally conscious
to the point of
every single second of every single day
they're trying to produce as little
waste as possible that's very admirable
the zero waste movement though is a
little it's a little um well maybe it's
kind of like minimalism right like once
you call yourself something like you're
steeped in irony but like the zero waste
movement if you're using electricity
there's waste involved with that if
you're using water there's waste
involved with that yes um
there's always going to be a little bit
of waste so the reason why i'm bringing
this up this isn't to put down the zero
waste movement as much as to say hey
look it's not a matter of
if you're creating waste
it's how much waste are you creating and
why are you creating it
that's a great question and that
catherine is how i would approach the
scrapbooking thing is ask yourself that
question like why do you want to create
this waste well you want to create art
you want to bring yourself some joy you
want to bring yourself some purpose
and that's great that's a good reason to
create a little bit of scrapbook wasting
now if her passion was i don't know
changing oil and dumping it down the
gutters in the street i would probably
say okay catherine maybe you don't want
to do that there's a pretty big
environmental cost with that right but
if her passion was changing oil in a way
that produced as little waste as
possible yeah that might actually be a
wonderful thing for the world totally
right and so
you're creating something right now
it might produce a little bit of
quote-unquote waste
but what you're doing is not wasted
a person who pursues art in its purest
form
i applaud that person
i pat them on the back i hold them up
as an example
of the way that many of us want to be
because art often gets ruined by what
commerce
oh check out this ad that i'm putting on
my
tv show or podcast or magazine or
whatever it might be art gets ruined by
commerce what you're doing here
doesn't have a commercial aspect not
that it would be evil if it did
right but catherine you're doing
something that is pure
and yes it might you might throw away a
few pieces of paper every now and then
i'm not going to worry about that at all
and by the way if you end up with 22
scrapbooks that's not the real problem
if the average american household has
300 000 items in it
and you have 22 scrap books that's not
even a drop in the bucket if you're
being intentional in all these other
areas of life think about how much less
waste you are producing
and yes you'll be intentional in this
area as well you're not going to pour
heaps of waste out of your scrap booking
into a dump site but you might have a
few little scraps here and there and by
definitions that's what scrap booking is
but
also by definition scrapbooking means
you're taking some scraps things that
might otherwise be waste
and you're turning it into art
how pure is that
catherine i'd love to send you a copy of
our book everything that remains ryan
and i moved to a cabin in the middle of
nowhere a decade ago
and there was one traffic light in 3 400
square miles and we wrote the first
draft of this book it's called
everything that remains and it's one of
our favorite things that we've ever done
if you like our podcast you'll enjoy the
audiobook version of everything that
remains or if you want the book book or
the ebook version it is a book that is
really about us letting go there's an
entire chapter in there of me dealing
with my mom's excess stuff and much of
her waist and and trying to sort through
what is essential what is junk
what is value adding
what might augment my life what would i
like to hold on to
and what do i need to let go of enjoy
that copy of everything that remains
alabama do we have any questions from
our live stream shout out to our patrons
on the live stream yeah we do we have a
question from raquel what are the
origins of spring cleaning where did we
get started with that
you know what i want to talk about the
origins of spring cleaning on the
maximal episode because i'm going to
dive deep into the origins of spring
cleaning i think a lot of us don't
really understand where that comes from
yeah and i want to talk about how we can
implement spring cleaning like a year
long or all year round spring cleaning
yeah so that we're not overwhelmed in
the spring how about one more question
from the live stream this one is from
arbory my wife and i have about 20 boxes
of clothes in a storage place for our
future child but we clearly have too
much how can we approach this if we're
not sure what we'll need
to name the kid fashionista
uh my daughter's eight and she uh when i
asked her i don't know maybe six months
or so ago what she wants to be when she
grows up just
uh are there any professions and she
said i want to be a fashionista
i'm like i don't really i'm like what
does a fashionista do she she's like i
don't really know
and
i think we often hold on to those things
because we assume they're going to be
useful yeah it's so hypothetical that's
the ultimate just in case item
we have a minimalist rule book you can
find it the minimalists.com rule book
it's free you can download it there's 16
rules for living with less but ryan
they're just boundaries really and these
rules are extremely adjustable two of
the rules in there one's the just in
case rule anything that i'm holding on
to just in case i can let go of
because i can replace it for less than
twenty dollars in less than 20 minutes
wherever i'm wherever i am that's
certainly true with kids clothes because
kids clothes are almost free if you go
to any swap meet or um a secondhand
store
you can find kids clothes for nothing on
craigslist right so you're spending
money you're spending more than nothing
right now to hold on to clothes that are
worth essentially nothing the other rule
that really came to mind is the just for
when i
items rule and so just for win it's
different from just in case items just
for when items are items you're holding
on to
that you know you're certain you will
use
these don't fall in that category right
now you are uncertain as to how much of
these you will use
when you will use them
like my toilet paper is a just for win
item sure
i'm certain i'm going to use it i hope i
don't have to use it all today
but it will come in handy and i don't
want to run out so i'm like uh oh when i
need it i don't want to have to run to
the store immediately yeah because that
would be a messy trip to the store
and so
yes i do have some toilet paper on hand
but
i didn't hold on to ella's clothes
in case we might have some other kid in
the future i decided to let go of those
things why
because if i stop clinging to it someone
else could get value from those things
but if i lock them up in those clutter
coffins in a storage mausoleum
no one is ever going to get any value
from those things as i cling
to that horde
man uh the
the reason why people
let go of things the reason why i
started to let go of things was because
i had a lot of angst like i had some
pain that i had to
address
and it sounds like
uh
this gentleman has some pain that he
needs to address
so uh yes i like setting up the
different boundaries maybe you keep two
boxes instead of 22 boxes whatever it is
but my favorite boundary or my favorite
rule to apply to this is the spontaneous
combustion rule
so you ask yourself if all of those
children's clothes if they spontaneously
combusted
how would i feel right now and if you
would feel relief
then let those go man but if you would
feel pain and stress and and angst and
oh my god i gotta replace 22 boxes of
clothes and hold on to them but i'm
willing to bet that uh you probably feel
a little bit of relief or maybe ask
yourself if half the box is
spontaneously combusted
and with the beautiful thing about that
is if you would feel relief you actually
get to pick the the half of those boxes
that do spontaneously combust you could
tick-tock that danny
ryan what time you got you know what
time it is josh it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments your smart
remarks to 937-202
even your eggplant emojis
we get quite a few of those those texts
literally go to both of our phones and
we respond to as many people as we can
uh in fact yeah you can just text us
937-202-4654
and we interact with you there but we
also answer some questions here during
the lightning round via those text
messages the text message that um
someone just uh tweeted or text us from
ukraine
and they were talking about how
uh they were listening to our podcast
because they because of the situation
that's going on there
like they had to get up and go
so they were kind of stressing about
what do i bring what do i need what uh
yeah and um yeah i mean i mean just
being able to have communications like
that via text is unbelievable yes indeed
it's inspiring now during the lightning
rounds where ryan and i do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maximums in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media if you
like and now you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com alabama looks like we
have a question here from kelsey how do
you determine which things are worth
storing
here's a
here's a pithy answer for you then we'll
unpack it this is an oldie but a goodie
ryan
organizing
is well planned hoarding yeah
every time we organize something what
we're really doing
is organizing our horde so of course
the best way to organize your stuff is
to get rid
of most of it yeah and so kelsey
the way that you do that
is by looking at the things that you
know
you can let go of it's starting
somewhere you can start with something
like the 30-day minimalism game you can
download our free calendar on our
website the minimalists.com game you can
partner up with someone and it'll give
you that momentum you need to let go of
the access stuff because if you have a
lot of things
like most people do
[Music]
you'll know right away some of these
things i know i can get rid of one thing
today right and tomorrow i know i can
get rid of two things and the next day i
know i can get rid of three things
that's how the minimalism game works and
by day 10 you're getting rid of 10
things and you're getting that momentum
to let go you're not getting rid of the
things that are important to you the
things that add value to your life
you're getting rid of the things that
are in the way so it's not about
holding on to the things that add value
first it's about eliminating the things
you know are in the way amen
understanding the why
will help you better understand the what
and the how
yes so it's not how do you determine
which things are worth storing so why
are you asking this question
is it because you want to be freer you
want to be lighter you want to be more
mobile you want to be able to turn your
life around on a dime like once you
understand the why the how and the what
really kind of uh uncovers itself
absolutely because when you understand
that why
then the what the things
they support that why yeah we try to
back into a why well right i'm gonna
hold on to these 100 000 items yeah
but they may not help you get to the why
in fact they might get in the way of
your
why yeah
alabama we've got a whole bunch more to
talk about but first real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist you know the folks over at
cameo they've been asking us to to join
cameo so we can charge people to make
videos for you know whatever and we
decided not to do that we didn't want to
do it but
we can't just randomly make a bunch of
videos every single day for folks so we
have a tier of people on our patreon
where for no additional charge if you're
part of that tier you get a whole bunch
of other things as well it's called the
vip tier it's limited to 250 people
we'll send you a personalized video so
if you want to celebrate your wife's
birthday or your husband's bar mitzvah
or whatever it is um we will send a
video congratulating you whatever it's
all part of what the regular tier so
we're not going to charge you money for
those videos if you are one of our vip
patrons you can get a video a custom
video from me and ryan will say whatever
you want in any language you want
as long as it's english
yeah husband's bar mitzvah isn't a bar
mitzvah like when a
boy becomes a man at like 13. yes that's
why it was funny oh
i love jokes they are funny
his favorite jokes are funny ones yeah
exactly i don't like the not funny ones
yeah me either and neither does my
daughter although she doesn't think
anything i say is funny unfortunately
occasionally i'll throw a dad joke in
there and she's uh the one i told her
recently
i said um
i think actually ryan will like this one
i said hey ella
three conspiracy theorists walk into a
bar
now tell me that's a coincidence
[Laughter]
that's good she just looked at me and
kind of blinked twice yeah
anyway if you want some custom videos
from from me and ryan celebrating
something you can uh i think there's
only about 20 or 30 slots left on that
tier no pressure i'm not asking you to
join it we just wanted to put that
information out there for you it is
available and if you're one of the
existing vips thank you so much that is
available to you as well
patreon.com
the minimalist alabama what else you got
for us right now here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
hey josh and ryan my name is zach miller
calling from minneapolis minnesota just
listen to your podcasts i i'm not sure
if it was on clothing or
travel or something like that but you
mentioned clothing and i just figured
i'd share uh what i've learned about my
clothing choices
on my journey to becoming a minimalist
my three objectives
for any sort of clothing item that i
would own is that it is functional
it is durable and it is stylistic
stylistically versatile
meaning i can wear it to any
or most of the activities that i would
partake in
i generally stick to neutral or earth
tones this way it
gets rid of the need for brands or logos
and i can again pretty much wear it
anywhere
pop and color every once in a while with
an outerwear maybe a rain jacket
or a backpack or something like that
helps to identify that it's yours as
well
which is a useful function
and again mostly what i wear is geared
towards function
what will i use it for can i use it for
many different things whether it be
professional business
or going on a hike
my name is craig i'm calling from the
toledo ohio area
and my comment is for susan who was
wondering about keeping baby clothes
to remind her of when her newborn came
home
this i'm sure will certainly expand into
other projects and papers and artwork as
the child progresses from preschool
through kindergarten up to fourth fifth
grade
when most of that artwork is produced
we kept a lot of that stuff
all of that sort of thing went into a
big box because at the time when they're
very young that seems like very
invaluable stuff to keep
and ultimately
as the children grew older
we started to sort through it
and realized that only certain pieces
meant something or that were had
something that we really liked and those
were items that got scanned or
photographed
and even now
my children are 16 and 19
and as we still find various things
they kind of look at it and say
i don't know why you're keeping that
and so then we take a photograph of it
and then it goes in the trash
so they don't seem to mind at all and we
keep remembrances of the pieces we
like the best in a digital format and
the rest of it goes away so i guess what
i'm saying is give yourself a little
permission
[Music]
having a baby is a very exciting thing
and as they grow up you will
find more value in certain things than
others
and the things that you seem
to want to hold on the most right now
may not seem as important in a few years
so give yourself a little a little time
and a little uh
availability to kind of hold on to stuff
for a little while but not forever
all right y'all i've been told that
jordan no more who is manning all of our
our cameras over here he's uh he has
jumped into the live chat he's been
trolling
us during the live stream so the patrons
get a little sample of that i think the
thing he just said in the in the live
chat was someday is the eighth day of
the week and it never arrives
that's good jordan you can tweet that
podcast sean that's good man uh by the
way ryan before we get into our added
value segment this week i'm going to
turn all of y'all on to some new music
that you're really going to enjoy in
fact danny has not stopped playing this
album um our our resident um
gen zier they call him zillenials or is
is alabama as a lineal um
no she's genuine i'm pretty sure
is millennial like a cusp
anyway no uh we'll get to the added
value in a second i've got something
from patreon this is we have a um well a
really quick testimonial from one of our
lovely patreon subscribers hannah said i
thoroughly enjoy listening to your
private podcast your message of
intentional living has had a tremendous
impact on my overall
my overall well-being and sense of peace
so much so that i had a dream the other
night that i was about to die in a car
crash and instead of panicking i called
my cousin to tell him how much i loved
him and how happy i am because i'm
living more intentionally needless to
say i'm grateful to be a simpleton
oh wow
so we uh our patreon supporters are
called simpletons
and we we've reclaimed the term right
because well we are all simpletons ryan
and i are the king and queen simpleton
yes yes we'll let you guess which one's
the king and which one's the queen by
the way our our patreon is not just a
some sort of bonus content where we
throw up scraps and cutting room floor
things it's the other half of the show
so every week we do two podcasts like
the other third three quarters of the
show that's true
but we do two episodes every week we do
a minimal episode every tuesday maximal
episode every thursday so it's a free
public episode a private episode every
every thursday and you can check that
out at patreon.com
the minimalists ryan
for added value this week what do you
got
there's a hip-hop artist named gunna
okay we were listening to him a lot on
tour
the oh yeah the new album is ds4 eva
and uh this song is called
and i thought it was so appropriate for
this episode i've been saving it for a
few weeks
this song is called die alone
and it opens up with this lyric
i don't want to be alone
i don't want to die
alone
and quite often isn't that what we're
doing
when we're holding on to all of this
stuff
oh i'm gonna hold on to these things
because i don't want to die alone
it's what rahm das talks about when he
says you are encrusted with identity
oh
and so we are all encrusted with this
identity and our stuff
becomes who we are and we cling to those
things because we are terrified
of dying alone
enjoy the song
by the way we've got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like what
are 100 things that we would say to our
18 year old selves ryan about minimalism
also my kid is the kind that dumps bins
to find what he wants at playtime do you
have any simple tips
on the best practical way to store and
organize his toys
what specifically do joshua and ryan do
to set the stage in their homes every
evening plus a million more questions
for the minimalists and if you want to
hear all that check out the minimalist
private podcast visit
patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain access to hundreds
of hours of private archives recordings
of live events exclusive home tours and
our private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers
like you you can follow the minimalists
on tik-tok facebook instagram and
twitter at the minimalists if you want
our podcast show notes in your inbox
thanks to our good friend podcast shawn
he'll send them right to you over at the
minimalists.com just sign up for our
email list over there on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team did i
say jordan no more i did say it
jordan no more
no more
i'm joshua fields movement reminding you
to love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
being here y'all thanks
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'd be fine
without it